e
[Música]
essa é o teu cu ou simplesmente Ok como
ficou carinhosamente conhecida
Dominique boyita rins universo uma vez
escreveu com muita razão que ok era uma
pequena geleira com a grande história
para contar eu vim aqui hoje para contar
esta grande história pra vocês e pra
mostrar porque e como a vida EA morte de
uma geleira estão interligadas a nossa
saúde EA saúde do nosso planeta
o ok tinha uma grande família ela era
das langjokull
128 conglomerados de gelo da Islândia
quando Ok era criança ela tinha a 120
anos atrás ela me devia cento
e a 120 anos atrás ela me envia 38
quilômetros quadrados em 1986 contudo
seu corpo já aqui tipo e quase sem vida
não iria mais do que três quilômetros
quadrados
Ok morreu em 2014 seca e sem luz
Esse é o seu Cadáver
o rock morreu quando o seu corpo já não
conseguia mais excluir uma geleira
parada uma geleira morta Dizem os
especialistas
e quando o que morreu um grupo de
cientistas Subiu até o topo do vulcão
sobre o qual ela dormia e colocou esta
placa e é uma espécie de
o monumento ao mesmo tempo um Epitáfio
triste e constrangedor ele diz o
seguinte Ok é a primeira geleira a
perder o seu status de geleira nos
próximos 200 anos todas as geleiras do
mundo seguiram pelo mesmo caminho
este monumento e para demonstrar que nós
sabíamos o que estava acontecendo e o
que precisava ser feito só vocês saberão
se nós fizemos o que era preciso o texto
escrito pelo celebrado escritor irlandês
André magnago não e termina com a data
da cerimônia a gosto de 2019 e com o
índice de dióxido de carbono na
atmosfera naquele momento 415 partes por
milhão o índice mais alto da história
humana moderna o número que só piorou
desde então esse é o gado de agora 2021
420 partes por Milhão
é por causa deste número ok morreu por
causa deste número todas as geleiras do
mundo deve morrer Esse número é o índice
de uma doença e como toda doença tem os
seus sintomas e como toda cura também
começa com a consciência e aceitação da
doença a carta escrita por entre
magnazil se chama uma carta para o
futuro nós sabíamos o que estava
acontecendo e o que precisava ser feito
o segundo a ONU 21 das 46 geleiras
declaradas patrimônio natural da
humanidade pela Unesco
desapareceram nos próximos anos até 2100
olha no relógio já é amanhã Isso
significa que paisagens como essa do
Monte Perdido dos Pirineus ou essa os
parques gelados da Argentina o esta um
dos destinos turísticos mais populares
do mundo nos Alpes ou esta do Monte dos
das montanhas rochosas entre os Estados
Unidos e Canadá o mesmo essa a
Cordilheira do Himalaia no Nepal
simplesmente desapareceram Isso
significa que as relações do Futuro
nossos filhos e netos jamais conheceram
essas paisagens deslumbrantes
é isso já está acontecendo agora vejo
essas duas fotos a primeira delas foi
tirada por Cola em Baxter quando ele
resolveu pegar a sua família tirar umas
férias para conhecer uma das massas
polares mais importantes da Europa a
foto debaixo do seu filho querendo
Baxter que 30 anos depois resolveu
voltar ao mesmo local
para lembrar daquela viagem em família
foi isso que ele encontrou
400 km de gelo em um simplesmente
desaparecido
Mas é bom lembrar que as geleiras são
documentos onde os cientistas correm as
evidências do aquecimento global elas
determinam os ciclos climáticos
equilibram a temperatura do planeta e
guardam a maior reserva de água doce do
mundo de onde está em grandes rios ao
redor dos quais como na Bíblia cresce a
vida
com
a morte do ok não é ético no evento
cancelado
a tempestade do da Sony seca é essências
aquecimentos Oceano Atlântico os males
contra os continentes o risco de vermos
uma Veneza inteira por exemplo e não
data momentos uma Amazona inteira
devastada movendo seus povos morrendo
devido à poluição das cidades
solos e das Águas
E
isso não apenas nos coloca em uma Nova
Era geológica no antropoceno mas vi
antes da sexta onda de extinção da vida
na Terra segundo os especialistas neste
momento o processo tem duas grandes
diferenças em relação a tudo que já
aconteceu na história da vida sobre esse
planeta a primeira delas tem a ver com a
velocidade agora Dizem os especialistas
a onda de extinção da vida na Terra é de
100 a 1000 vezes mais rápido do que foi
há 66 milhões de anos atrás quando
desapareceram os dinossauros e mais 75
por cento das formas de vida que havia
no planeta naquela época a segunda
característica é que pela primeira vez
na história um Entre todos os outros
seres é responsável pela destruição do
todo só para vocês terem uma ideia
segundo a wwf nos últimos 40 anos a
humanidade já exterminou sessenta por
cento de todos os animais que havia no
planeta é o caso da América do Sul a
cidade ainda mais alarmante 89 por cento
oitenta e nove porcento de todos os
animais que havia na América do Sul
foram mortos nos últimos 40 anos
é um deles Essa elefanta ela essa
elefanta simpática uma vovó chamada
samba samba morrer morreu no santuário
dos elefantes da Chapada dos Guimarães
no Mato Grosso no dia vinte e seis de
dezembro de 2019 dois meses depois de
chegar ao Brasil vinda do Chile a onde
trabalhava como escrava em um circo o
samba que tinha 56 anos e pesava mais ou
menos seis toneladas sofria de problemas
renais crônicos decorrentes da falta de
água potável e de uma vida de sacrifício
samba nasceu na Ásia trabalhou na
Argentina e no Chile antes de chegar ao
Brasil seu corpo estava cheio de
cicatrizes decorrentes
e quando o gama morreu o Santuário dos
elefantes lançou uma nota de falecimento
que diz o seguinte é com imenso pesar
que comunicamos o falecimento de samba
saímos para encontrá-la e a descobrimos
em um dos seus lugares favoritos o
recinto número 4 além do riacho ela
aparecia está dormindo sua morte deve
ter sido repentina pois a grama o seu
redor estava intocada apenas um lindo
elefante deitado em um belo pasto os
olhos suavemente fechados eo rosto doce
tão calmo como costumava ser
o elefante são animais sensíveis e
inteligentes estão na lista de extinção
A cada 15 minutos um deles é assassinado
no mundo devido à caça Outros tantos
morrem devido à fome
decorrente da destruição dos seus
habitates naturais se tu continuar assim
nos próximos 20 anos não teremos mais
elefantes na face da terra segundo a
união internacional para a proteção da
natureza
e a população de elefantes que habitavam
por exemplo as Savanas africanas
diminuiu em 86 por cento nos últimos 40
anos
também aqui vamos precisar escrever a
nossa Carta Para o Futuro nós
e nós nós
sabíamos o que estava acontecendo o que
precisava ser feito essa é uma doença
produzida pela própria humanidade uma
doença que vem se agravando nos últimos
tempos devido ao avanço dos poderes
tecnológicos contra a natureza EA um
estilo de vida Consumista e predatório
que nós estamos levando
é muito antes que os cientistas do clima
começassem a lançar os seus relatórios o
filósofo alemão Hans e o nas publicou em
1979 aquele que poderia ser considerado
um dos livros mais importantes do
pensamento ético contemporâneo o
princípio responsabilidade
ensaio de uma ética para a civilização
tecnológica neste livro rasionas chama
atenção para a catástrofe ambiental que
se a vizinha e para responsabilidade do
ser humano diante desses fatos para
yonas só o ser humano pode salvar as
geleiras os elefantes e todos os demais
seres vivos incluindo a si mesmo porque
só o ser humano tem um poder de
destruição então larga escala mas
sobretudo porque só Nós seres humanos
somos capazes de responsabilidade para
si só nós temos uma coisa que só nós
podemos ter então realizar esta coisa
equivale a realizar plenamente aquilo
que somos
em outras palavras para yonas o ser
humano só se realiza plenamente Quando
assumir a sua responsabilidade diante da
natureza para isso ele precisa ouvir o
apelo da vida reconhecer a dignidade
própria de todos os seres vivos e agir
individual e coletivamente para Salvalus
e todo tudo todos estamos interligados
por isso que realizou nesse escreveu e
uma vida extra-humana empobrecida uma
natureza empobrecida significa também
uma vida humana empobrecida todos tudo
estamos interligados
é por isso que
e o biólogo e ambientalista renedu go de
América norueguesa gro brundtland
propuseram o conceito de saúde
planetária
o mesmo que ocorreu a fundação
Rockefeller EA revista científica the
lancet quando propuseram 2015 que a
saúde e planetária fosse reconhecida com
uma nova área de estudos capaz de dar
conta de compreender e de contribuir
para que o ser humano pudesse agir para
reverter as consequências nefastas da
sua presença sobre o meio ambiente ao
mesmo tempo compreendendo como os
efeitos dessa dessa presença devem ser
devem ser estudados em relação aos à
saúde e ao bem-estar do ser humano o que
se cientistas Estão dizendo é o que o
Husky o nas já tinha dito
e a saúde dos seres humanos depende da
Saúde da terra uma terra doente dá
margem ao aparecimento de muitas
epidemias e pandemias cuja a tragédia a
nossa geração conhece agora
o e sobre a qual precisa atuar para
evitar que se repita no futuro todos
sabemos que a destruição dos habitats
naturais e a caça o transporte o tráfico
de plantas e animais silvestres quebram
as barreiras protetivas que nos separam
dos agentes patógenos sem isso nós
ficamos absolutamente vulnerável
e aliás Podemos dizer que a
responsabilidade a estratégia da vida
contra aquilo que a sua própria Marca
essa bunda é habilidade uma
vulnerabilidade que é própria do nosso
planeta em grego Terra significa errante
e referência Clara ao fato de que nós
geramos como uma exceção no meio de um
monte de pedras mortas flagrando nesse
espaço escuro
é uma vez Pascal disse e escreveu que o
silêncio desses espaços infinitos o
apavorava
Olá hoje nós podemos dizer que devemos
nos apavorar diante do grito de socorro
da natureza no choro dos mamíferos do
Canto dos Pássaros na subiu do vento
sobre as Palmeiras uma agulha das
Vertentes ou no barulho das ondas do mar
tudo isso representa a voz sagrada da
natureza pedindo socorro a nossa
resposta deve se dar na forma de novo
tipo de amor um amor comprometido e
responsável um amor cantado por Caetano
Veloso na sua terra
terra por mais distante o errante
navegante
quem jamais
esqueceria
Ferrari Terra por mais distante
o errante navegante
quem jamais
te esqueceria quem poderia esquecer das
Ferragens e dizem que os astronautas que
viravam o espaço pelas primeiras vezes
tiveram que olhar para trás e quando
eles viraram para trás foi isso que eles
viram um planeta todo azul todo cheio
d'água todo todo todo grávido
é com esse planeta que nós temos uma
relação amorosa também aqui a música do
Caetano é uma espécie de carta para o
futuro nós sabíamos o que estava
acontecendo e o que precisava ser feito
só você saber não se nós fizemos o que
era preciso o destinatário dessa carta é
muito claro são as gerações do Futuro
entre elas está o meu sobrinho-neto
Anthony ouça um som do seu coração
e
esse é o som da vida pedindo socorro
esse
é o som da vida desesperadamente
querendo viver é com Esta é para esse
Grito de Socorro e nós temos que ter a
nossa resposta
é para esta gente parentoni e todos os
outros que nós temos que deixar um
planeta saudável é com eles que nós
temos uma relação de responsabilidade e
de compromisso a primeira tarefa cósmica
da humanidade garantir que a terra
continue sendo um planeta saudável no
futuro
só eles O Anthony e todos os outros
saberão se nós fizemos o que era preciso
E aí